[Musique]
marie petit au bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau de tv 78 ou ce vip
que l'on va entièrement vous consacrez
vous êtes ici parce que vous sortez un
premier livre qui s'appelle royal
passion voilà et qui parle de deux
yvelinois extrêmement célèbre on y
reviendra après donc vous êtes auteur
vous êtes si blogueuse comment s'appelle
votre blog qu'une histoire qu'une
histoire est alors combien de personnes
le consulte alors à la louche en est la
louche en moyenne par mois et à 60 mille
pages vues
kamel et j'ai surtout une communauté
très intéressantes sur facebook de 27000
personnes s'étaient fait quand qui est
très important donc voilà blogueuse
auteure et vous êtes aussi community
manager dans le domaine de la culture
évidemment on lit c'est à dire plus
précisément fait croire alors je suis
community manager indépendante et que
j'aide les
organisations culturelles les châteaux
les monuments les musées beaucoup
simplement les entreprises qui ont un
pied dans le secteur culturel
ouais à se mettre en avant à se
développer sur les réseaux sociaux qui
est extrêmement important aujourd'hui
d'accord à communiquer vous rédigez les
articles et vous vous les mettez en
lumière voilà mention tout ça très bien
et vous serez présente je le dis
maintenant au cas où on oublie au salon
histoire de lire à versailles les 24 et
25 novembre pour ce livre chez
tallandier donc ce livre alors déjà cet
amour de l'histoire vous êtes
historienne vous êtes communiquant te ra
quo témoin un peu oui eh bien j'ai un
parcours un petit peu atypique c'est
vrai j'ai fait des études de
communication et de marketing master en
communication mais se lisait dans les
services
et puis en fait j'ai développé cette
passion de l'histoire en parallèle donc
déjà l'écriture depuis tout petit
l'histoire est venue se greffer dessus
donc j'avais un peu des multiples
casquettes ma dire la communicante
l'historienne de coeur un petit peu et
puis la passionnée de lettres de lecture
l'écriture et finalement c'est grâce à
mon blog que j'ai pu combiner un petit
peu toutes ses facettes d'accord et
votre blog alors plus d'histoire il est
orienté sur sur quoi exactement
plus précisément alors plus mon histoire
c'est aborder l'histoire par la petite
porte
regin mais c'est des anecdotes
culturelle sur les grands personnages de
l'histoire ou sur des personnages moins
connus que j'ai envie de faire découvrir
aux gens d'accord voilà donc beaucoup
d'anecdotes en peau croustillante mais
toujours très source et oui c'est ça
qu'on avance et rire et rassurez moi
n'ont jamais remis on est alors comment
vous travaillez pour découvrir toutes
ces anecdotes
alors je travaille beaucoup grâce à
gallica par exemple toutes les bases de
données en ligne qui en scanner les
documents d'époque par exemple des
mémoires délai directement ou
indirectement à la source et beaucoup la
presse de l'époque aussi est évidemment
la bibliographie existantes
ouais d'accord et les nouveaux
personnages alors vous les rencontrez
comme ça au hasard de vos recherches
proche des les nouveaux personnages veut
dire les personnages moins connus ou oui
alors c'est au fil de mes lectures
surtout bon d'accord vous repérez voilà
parfois il ya un personnage qui
surgissent à un destin des raisons et
j'ai envie de creuser donc après je vais
chercher d'autres sources les visages
mélange un peu à ma sauce
voilà ouais ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
c'est très bien écrit vous avez un style
très agréable et ça c'est vraiment très
très facilement et très intéressant ça
évidemment
alors pour revenir aux deux personnages
donc là nous avons dit passion dix
portraits voilà parce que vous êtes allé
chercher chez dix personnages
historiques ce qui les anime elle fait
leur jardin secret alors leur passion
voilà et vous en avez choisi en guise et
nous ce qui nous intéresse ce sont louis
xiv n'importe quoi lille 15
j'étais pas loin louis cainne ça et nous
voyons à l'écran et louis xiii alors
louis 15 quelle était sa passion
racontez nous alors la passion de louis
15 on aurait pu j'aurais pu choisir les
femmes j'ai choisi déjà oui il est fermé
on en a beaucoup parlé aussi
beaucoup trop parlé la chasse donc c'est
pas le seul roi être passionné de chasse
mais chez lui ça a un côté extrêmement
important pour son équilibre
psychologique en fait il ne peut pas
s'en passer
tilt à lacets vitesse est un exutoire en
fait d'accord voilà donc qui chassent
quatre cinq fois par semaine et ça
devient un petit peu partie prenante du
système de cours donc à québec alors
c'était parce que justement part d'un
jeune couple de seconde amende mais
comment est-ce qu'ils travaillent ou est
ce qu'il trouve le temps de travail et
de diriger le pays s'y passe son temps à
cheval à courser le cerd ont
contrairement à ce qu'on a dit louis 15
est quelqu'un d'extrêmement conscient de
son devoir de monarque qui est quand
même le temps de travail et de recevoir
ses ministres et ensuite la chasse même
si ça prend un temps important donc gros
à ces journées parce que en fait ça fait
partie aussi du système de courtes à
dire que ça devient un véritable
privilège d'aller chasser avec le roi on
attend d'être conviés à la chasse et le
moment où on peut avoir des confidences
avec lui parce que en fait il a une
liste c'est lui qui se fait c'est lui
qui choisit invité les invités semaine
corse et ses affinités
c'est bien d'avoir mené avec certaines
personnes ou non oui d'accord ok donc
quand on a les demies depuis il allie le
travail et la chasse exactement
voilà très bien et alors pourquoi est ce
que vous dites que c'est nécessaire à
son élan vital qu'est ce qui est ce qui
est choquant c'est un personnage très
complexe très
[Applaudissements]
solitaire mélancolique il a eu une
enfance très seul très difficile il est
devenu roi à peine six ans il avait plus
de parents il n'avait pas de frère pour
partager ces jeux est entouré d'adultes
qu'il a grandi très vite vous aussi pour
ça que s'est attaché aux femmes qui va
de son entourage d'abord et puis après
les femmes qu'il a rencontrées au cours
de son existence
mais les femmes ça lui pose un problème
religieux c'est il sentait qu'ils
pêchaient autrefois son épouse avec sa
maîtresse alors que la chasse c'est un
avertissement qui lui permet de se
défouler ouais ouais et alors il a aussi
beaucoup aimé le développement d'allah
l'art cynégétique 10 de sa main qu'est
ce que c'est l'art cynégétique mais
c'est tout ce qui est autour
du sport cependant pas cher ouais c'est
tout ce qui est artistique autour d'une
aventure et sculptures donc il convient
d artistes à ces chasses wilairot disait
croquer moi ça oui par exemple par
exemple où ils leur commandait des
portraits un peu plus convenue mais il
ya des scènes de chasse extraordinaire
dix tableaux monumentaux de genève aux
curieux étaient peints par des artistes
commandé par louis 15 9 or là aussi des
portraits de chiens et les portraits de
chiens car il aimait beaucoup ses chiens
il aimait beaucoup ses chats il en avait
beaucoup qui connaissait par leur nom
chacun d'entre eux attention ouais et
bill commandes et des portraits qui
rejoignait ses salons ces appartements
dans ses différentes résidences
l'examinant toujours auprès de lui ces
chiens en portrait moins cher ok très
bien alors on va maintenant passer à
louis xiii qui est moins moins souvent
évoquée pourquoi on parle moins de ce
louis xiii
qu'est ce qui est quand même régné vingt
ans oui mais en fait lui tresse un peu
le mal aimé parce que déjà il est coincé
entre deux règnes
important donc le sympathique henri iv
oui et le grand roi soleil louis xiv
donc on a tendance à un peu à oublier
qu'il ya eu louis xiii entre les lieux
c'était l'attentât contre les bucks et
pour parler de richelieu voilà pas
d'accord ok puis c'est un personnage un
petit peu austère qui a ce côté un peu
l'ombrageux mélancolique aussi à
l'accord même à appeler ou 13 juste
oui oui c'est un des seuls monarque que
une popularité constante tout au long de
son règne qui a été aimé par le peuple
depuis le début de son règne jusqu'à sa
mort oui donc finalement les justes ceux
qui sont un peu loyaux et et de bonnes
personnes sont moins intéressants que
que d'autres démontrent
incontestablement de jeu car pêcher
quelques maîtresse alors lui qualité sa
passion alors lui 13 il a eu une passion
qui se divise en plusieurs thématiques
en fait c'était un peu un artiste dans
l'âme d'accord et donc il était
passionné de musique de danse très petit
d'ailleurs très petit oui on a un
document exceptionnel qu'est le journal
de jean hérouard qui était son médecin
l'on en fait qui fourmille d'anecdotes
sur sa jeunesse mais on voit qu'il était
effectivement subjugué par la musique
des ces deux trois ans ah oui ah oui
vraiment il écoutait il pouvait rester
immobile dr c'était le seul
la seule chose qu'ils étaient capables
de le transcender comme ça j'aime la
maladie aussi mais elles étaient de gros
frais de maladie de crohn ou non qui
souffrait et ça le rendait nerveux
inventé par deux essais thérapeutiques
voilà la musique et l art capable de
de l'apaiser de faire tenir en place
avec le dessin alors est destiné aussi
dessiné dessinée très jeune pareil il a
voulu imiter les peintres de la cour il
avait un talent dessinée juste mis là il
avait un vrai talent parce que déjà
j'aimerais voir à conserver certains de
ses dessins d'enfants ça c'est que ces
finales c'est le seul souverain vivant
on peut les voir comme on peut les voir
roussin seulement alors on peut les voir
dans le journal de joie roi mais oui il
a été reproduit aussi certains des
silhouettes et reproduit dans les
gazettes
c'est donc en cherchant sur internet on
peut voir la désyndicalisation on a des
corps si vous le savez assez amusant
ouais
et puis surtout c'était une passion qui
a duré donc adultes ils à continuer à
s'exercer sa musique est composée vous
dites aussi à composer à composer des
surtout de la musique religieuse il
était très touché par la musique
religieuse qui a du coup connu un essor
extraordinaire sous son règne
grâce à sa passion à lui mutine ou
l'hérédité wii se transformer parfois en
chef d'orchestre il sélectionnait les
instrumentistes des musiciens et tous
appareils en ayant toujours le temps de
travailler oui et de gouverner c'est à
dire que louis xiii était un homme
souvent campagne parce que son règne
c'est une des périodes un petit peu
compliqué quelques clics et associations
voilà c'était un roi militaire
américaine ce que je choisis mes entre
deux campagnes bon parfois il se passe
rien ou pendant une campagne quand on
attend quand il ya un siège etc
il trouvait le temps d'accord de
s'occuper autrement qu en maniant l'épée
quoi il maniait les instruments ou le
crayon le pinceau
ok bah écoutez c'est passionnant donc
bah écoutez on en sait plus à la lecture
de votre livre via d'autres portraits
aussi qu'ils sont tout aussi intéressant
si on veut vous voir en chair et en os
vous serez au salon donc comme j'ai dit
à leurs histoires de lire le 23 et 24
novembre ou 24 ou 25 francs grâce à un
tour du 23 24 novembre avec voilà
dans ces eaux là vous serez à versailles
vous preniez aussi pour la revue château
de versailles et d'autres leur geste
aurait là vous avez énormément de corde
à votre arc et je vous en félicite marie
petit os un grand merci
et puis très bientôt j'espère pour un
autre livre
mais en attendant on peut consulter
votre blog
il ya notamment un arc très intéressant
sur l'enfance des rois c'est ça oui la
petite dont 36 ans qui sont quelque
chose qui règne en elle après une
exposition qui paie en ce moment château
de ben la voilà en plus bon à très vite
marie utilise beaucoup
[Musique]